[Music]
all right thanks for coming out
everybody welcome to chess openings in
flames it's been a couple weeks maybe a
couple months by the time this video
comes out that since we've had a chest
opening to explain class so we're gonna
make it special by going over the sixth
most popular first move which is one be
three so this wasn't really popular
until it's still not popular but a bent
Larsen was the main proponent of this
opening back in the 70s he used it a lot
and with great success today we're going
to be looking at one of his games
against another Grandmaster and we'll
see how he employed plans so of course
it starts off with one be three and so
because white neglected this means the
center black most often takes advantage
of this by playing pawn to e5 or
sometimes pawn to d5 and so what blacks
plan is is to just use the central
control and gain some space in the
center while White's plan is to get this
Bishop on the long diagonal and then
break down this pawn and try to make
efficient more active so we'll see how
this once in this game so after Bishop
b2 Knight to c6 defending the pawn and
now white goes for this move III so
White's plan is actually kind of
counterintuitive so usually this
LightSquared Bishop is one of White's
best pieces and he does everything in
its power to to keep it alive because
usually you know and in pawn to d4
openings at least but they should come
to d3 have some attacking chances on the
Kings side but in this opening with one
b3 our main focus is really this piece
so almost all of our play is going to be
focused on improving this bishop so
after nice f6 what do you think White's
most popular movies
here what's up yeah Bishop to b5 so the
plan is again we want to break down this
pawn there it is okay I want to break
down this pawn by removing its defenders
so after pawn to d6 as what was played
in this game we'll see in a different
game later on that black actually tries
the strange move Bishop to d6 to defend
the pawn sometimes but for now we'll
stick with the most natural pawn to d6
white gets his night out to e2
why do you think Knight to f3 might not
be in line with White's plans
yeah exactly so again whites play is
directed towards improving this bishop
and opening up this diagonal for it so
to do that
Weiss eventually going to want to play
f4 to try to break down this pawn and
you obviously can't do that with the
knight on f3 and from E to the knight is
helping to support this push so black
again just develops this piece white
gets castled
black develops as other Bishop and I'm
not sure if we do it just yet but yeah
we actually do okay so again all of
whites moves are directed towards
opening up this Bishop like all of
whites pieces are working towards this
that's common goal and this is really a
common idea its lights going to try to
improve this Bishop and then once it's
improved who's going to use this dark
square control to try and win the game
so in the game black cracked under the
pressure and play E for so this is kind
of what white wanted to open this
diagonal but a black in the meantime is
gaining some very important control of
squares as well as just space in the
center and his phone is no longer under
attack so plenty of advantages and
disadvantage advantages to this so
White's going to continue with Knight to
g3 so again keeping blacks Center under
fire as well as eyeing some of these
squares so the knight coming to these
squares actually works well with this
Bishop it's pretty harmonious because it
is attacking the weak dark squares on
blacks King side so like I said now that
we've opened up this bishop we're going
to try to use the dark squares to our
advantage in in the resulting attack so
here black castle and white goes head
and snaps off the knight and black
recaptures
so keeping in mind with what I've been
saying about white trying to use the
dark squares to his advantage white
makes this trade because his white
squared bishop or light square bishop is
actually doing nothing to help him with
this plan let's see how he continued
after making that trade so now he goes
with c4 so he's just trying to restrict
black center and black continues with d5
anyways and now Knight to c3 just
getting the rest of his pieces into the
game after rook to e8 white plays rook
to c1 so I'm some of these some of these
pawns after Bishop to g4 we're going to
bring our knight back just keeping our
Queen here and opening up this bishop
once again as well as opening up this
rook to attack blacks weak pawns on the
C file so after Knight to d7 this is
actually where black started to uh maybe
make some mistakes so there's a very
common plan when White has a pawn
structure like this with a 2 B 3 and C 4
or even a yes with this pawn structure a
2 B 3 C 4 does anyone know how black
usually tries to weaken these pawns
tries to undermine them yep oh yes so
not necessarily this rook on the B file
because you might need it to support the
a5 a4 push but the a5 a4 is the correct
idea so black simply going to try to
open up this rook and weaken up weakened
use pawns on the half open file so this
is what black should have gone for just
immediately trying to get his counter
play on the Queen side without playing
moves like Knight to d7 which kind of
just wastes time which you might say you
know maybe he's bringing his Knight to
c5 i these squares but in the game it
actually turned out to be too slow of a
plan to be any good you needed to start
your Queen side counter play right away
so it might have continued something
like this with the trade off and then a
for completing the plan after something
like Knight to f5 and Bishop f8 black is
actually doing just fine here this
counter play is coming very quickly
while White's attacking chances are not
so clear it's not so clear how White's
going to to continue his attack but in
the game black instead opted for Knight
to d7 so we'll see how why continue so
h3 takes and recaptures with the Queen
because remember we want this night to
be eyeing these squares to attack blacks
weak and dark squares with the help of
our Bishop
so after Knight to c5 how do you think
well I continued here
because like is making some kind of play
of his own so we need to do something
with pace
any suggestion did Julian bishops
somewhere maybe not we want to create
some threats on the kingside yeah those
are both good moves so in the game I
think the more accurate move was Queen
to g4 and not actually to f5 because it
just creates a stronger threat right I
mean queen g4 threatened checkmate and
after nights f5 maybe black could hang
on with Bishop to f8 but I mean this
also looks very good for white yes
Julian
yeah Bishop f6 as well yeah this might
be a bit better but yeah so that's why
in the game or one of the reasons why
probably white opted for Queen to g4 so
with this in mind I'm actually gonna
back up a couple moves what do you think
blacks should have played instead of
making c5 because he had a very easy way
to just slow down White's attack and
maybe neutralize it all together
yeah just to get the bishop on the onto
the same diagonal so now White's
dark-squared attacking chances are very
much weakened by having this bishop
traded off so it might have continued
something like takes takes takes takes
and Knight to f5 again eyeing this
square and these squares but also may be
coming back to attacks this week pawn
and here white would actually be doing
very well because although his dark
squared bishop got triggered off he has
some serious positional advantages on
the Queen side for example we're
probably just going to double up our
rooks and put way too much pressure on
the C pawn the Queen might come to a6
eyeing the b7 square and a7 pawn and
this night will come back to d4 where it
supports all of these ideas quite nicely
so for example some like Queen d7 94
Burke c6 and I mean it's it's pretty
clear that White's doing very well here
in fact I think it would be fair to say
that black has just positionally lost
because he has no counter play this a
pawn can never come down the board and
all of his pieces are just tied down to
defending this pawn but that would have
been better than what happened in the
game because as we can see in the game
things ended very poorly after Queen to
g4 g6 now how do you think white can
continue to try to open things up
excuse me sorry yeah just pawn to f5 so
our plan is to get this rook in and
attack of black structure here so black
continued as if nothing was wrong and
completed his plan of attacking the
bishop and making a fork so how should
we respond to this do you think we
should just move the bishop out of the
way should we just move the rook out of
the way and defend our pieces or do we
have enough threats to just simply
ignore what black is doing okay so after
takes ticks what happens if sorry now
what not what do you do yet because this
fork is still relevant yeah Julian yeah
I work to f7 of course so in the game
work to f7 was played and black can't
ignore this of course because of
checkmate and if black were to recapture
yeah rook to f1 and again if we were to
come back this would be mate so you have
to block and then it actually kind of
matters how you take this bishop because
the endgame will be quite different
White's winning either way but
yeah Bishop f6 is slightly more accurate
because after Queen f6 you can throw in
Queen d7 check and now black needs is
King to stay on this Queen so we'll have
to block with the rook and then after
takes takes we have Queen takes place
before whereas if we were to do it the
other way after Queen here maybe black
can just try yeah Queen d7 actually
would be the move so we would have to we
would have to take here and then because
Lex king of silks so exposed white would
be still winning this game but it'd be a
lot less clear than just winning a full
rook and having the Queen fur rook
exchange so in the game black actually
resigned after this move which is I
guess fair enough so what's so review
really quick what happened in this scam
so starting off what are all of white's
moves what is their common goal in mind
right in the beginning of the opening
yep
one more time sorry yeah you want to
make the bishop stronger so you want to
open up this long diagonal to improve
your bishop so white did this by
attacking the defenders of the pawn
developed is Knight to this square
instead of f3 so support this pawn push
completed the pawn push and then
continued aiming for blacks dark squares
for the rest of the game as we saw in
major points where black went wrong what
should have you done here yet yeah yeah
p5 is a huge threat um well it's e5 and
Bishop d4 yeah that's uh that's a valid
point um
you have like physician at this point
was probably not so great but I thought
he was still doing doing okay here maybe
now in 97 and then you wanted to play
Bishop d4 so you want to play it
yep okay so I wanted to play Bishop f6
here and just make this trade okay maybe
h3 instead just to get the Queen to e2
instead but okay maybe Queenie one yeah
I'll try capturing you wanna take with
the night
yep and then maybe I'll just go ahead
and play it for c6 is hanging that's
very important yeah
so maybe I don't take my dad to play for
here b4 I was going to play 8/3
um yeah maybe your create now age three
yeah you got me there um okay uh yeah
that's a fair point
um I mean 97 was the worst move I just
thought that this this a five idea
needed to be placed sooner but so yeah I
don't think black is losing it here is
really the main mistake where black
played 95 when of course you should have
seen the danger that White's Bishop
presented and instead gone for Bishop to
f6 to neutralize its attack so again the
main points are White's play usually
resolves around revolves around the
bishop and the weak dark squares in
Black's camp and blacks play usually
revolves around using a central majority
or applying on the Queen side all right
any other questions about the game
alright we'll move right along
so here we're going to take a look at
the same opening line from black so with
E 5 and 96
III and Knight f6 but here we're going
to look at a different move rather than
pawn to d6 so we're going to look at the
strange-looking bishops p6 so blacks
point point with this is that he wants
to defend this pawn and also as well put
some more pressure on s4 to make that
brake harder to achieve but obviously
this comes with some drawbacks as though
as obviously this bishop is momentarily
in the way so yeah black's other idea is
that eventually he's going to play pawn
to e4 and then he can try to play Bishop
to e5 to trade off this bishop so we'll
see how white continues so in the game
white played 9 to a3 so why do you think
this was played yeah because if you want
to go to c4 and this takes advantage
right away of blacks kind of misplaced
for the moment bishop
so black really needs to do something
about this so in the game black chose to
solve this problem by playing Knight to
a5 so it's kind of a strange opening
sequence because it's both nice has gone
straight to the edges board where
general generally they don't belong but
it's okay for black to waste time like
this because now White's Bishop looks a
little silly and I'll probably end up
bringing it back to e2 or another square
and it's okay for white because it
forced black into spending spending this
move to defend against this Knight to c4
threat so game continued with Bishop to
e2 like I said the bishop was normal no
longer doing anything on b5 so it just
retreats and a6 is a move black wanted
to play anyways
preventing the knight from coming in
which white was threatening with Bishop
to e2 and after Knight to f3 this is a
kind of a change of plans from last time
right because last time we saw the
knight came into e2 to support this up
for push why do you think white changed
ideas here well first of all like the
bishop is on YouTube but now that you're
not playing f4 I guess my question is
what do you want to play to help the
bishop open the diagonal
yes so you want to play d4 eventually
which is a like f4 you're trying to just
attack this pawn until black can really
no longer handle it that's going to be
the break
why does playing floor playing for
instead of at four so Queen to e7 the
pawn is attacked twice so it needs to be
defended and now Knight to be won
the knight was attacked it has no future
on these two squares so it's simply
retreats and prepares to come back to
the more natural square castles and now
d4 so White's achieved his pawn break
and now black has to make a decision
does he want to take on d4 or play E for
so which do you think he went for
alright so in the game black actually
took on d4 the reasoning behind this I
believe can I go back okay the reasoning
behind this I believe is after E for
first of all this Bishop still doesn't
make any sense and it's still really
hemmed in behind this pawn and white can
eventually maybe think about playing c4
to d5 on his own time with everyone and
also this pawn might come under some
fired after stuff like night to tea to
c4 and Knight to c3 this pawn might
become hard to defend so for all of
those reasons black instead chose to
take on d4 so of course Knight takes we
want this diagonal open so we don't want
to put a pawn on it after Bishop to g4
now blacks plan has finally been
realized like I said in the beginning
the bishop went to d6 to maybe try to
get to this diagonal to tray itself off
for whites Bishop so nice to see three
just developing the five and Knight to
f3 so the point of whites play here was
that he gets to keep his Bishop so
that's why we did this kind of funny
move order was putting a knight here up
kind of blocking in our own Bishop for
the moment because
we wanted to evict blacks bishop before
continuing the game so bishop to be
seven white of course took on e5 trying
to weaken blacks dark squares so Queen
takes d5 and Bishop f3 trying to stomp
blacks blacks play because White's like
squares might have become kind of weak
if you were to allow this Bishop to
remain on this long diagonal so creamed
f5 was played and we traded here and now
I believe the castled
and after rook to e8 the opening is
pretty much over I'd say so again white
managed to keep this Bishop and open
this diagonal so I'd say he stands a bit
better here because because we succeeded
in completing both of these these tasks
and opening the diagonal as well as
keeping a bishop so blacks Point has to
play pretty accurately to make sure his
dark squares don't come under fire or he
doesn't have to give up a weakness
somewhere else
due to this so after Knight to e2 again
opening up the bishop Knight to c5 s3
was played so white wants to put his
pawns on light squares to uh help make
up for the lack of a light squared
bishop as well as keep the keep the path
open for the dark square bishop so there
are some tactics actually preventing you
from taking this pawn do you guys think
you see the answer not quite not quite
going to be for
oh well we actually need to play one
more move before we play Bishop to g4
yes so you want to play Knight to g3
first to get the Queen elsewhere and
then you can go ahead and after trades
play Bishop to g4 so why do you think
Bishop to g4 right away doesn't work
yeah you can just bring the rook back
and Queens move sideways so Knight to g3
is needed to actually win the material
and finally what do you think would
happen if black tried to stay on this
night to try to keep it defended a
bishop c1 would work here also maybe f4
is a good idea but the bishop c1 might
be the cleanest yep very good very good
following the rules of chess so after f3
block of course didn't take on e3 and
instead played d6 so now this Knight is
defended so that's the tactics defending
this pawn no longer work so white pushes
the e4 and black plays Queen to g5 so
what do you think white should be trying
to do here should he be playing for a
pawn break should he try to improve his
pieces where you think is pieces belong
where should I go yeah that's right so
you want to bring this Knight to f5 and
attack these same dark squares that we
talked about in the previous game so why
it went straight for it
he started right away with Knight to g3
rook to d8 and 9 - f 5 so already blacks
the dark squares are under some fire and
he should really in this position get
some central counter play going right
away he needs to open it up before white
gets some serious threats going
so in the game he played Knight to e6
which is fine it's a high F for square
with some threats of his own
so after g4 which is not the most
natural move but it does solve the mate
threat
this is sorry what we're asking it bent
Larsen actually isn't playing the game
it's Jo bhava do you remember
so yeah so pawn to g4 again this bishops
controls the dark squares so White's
placing his pawns on the light squares
to make up the lack of light squared
bishop as well as help support black
starts friendship so again he's
controlling f5 he's preventing this mate
threat so in my opinion black really
should be thinking about this d5 move
and but instead he plays Queen to f4
Queen to e1 and here I think the time
was the timing was perfect to be playing
d5 because a whites Queen is no longer
defending the square and the game could
could have continued something like
Queen to h4 creating some threats on
this Knight takes e5 takes takes and
recaptures here hitting the Queen and
obviously we don't want to take here
because after I think we can throw a
North to e1 and after this of course we
can just play Knight to h6 or take on f6
and in some order black will be falling
into some checkmating ideas maybe yeah
maybe thrown the check first because it
doesn't really matter probably there
might be some differences but say
instead black would play Queen to e5 to
control the square and after rook to e1
and rook to d2 White has to contend with
black zone piece activity which he made
by playing this pawn break but the White
has threats of
zone against blacks King and I believe
stock Beshear read the zero zero zero
and find some perpetual and all the
lines but yet this definitely have been
a lot better for blacks than what
happened in the game so he definitely
needed to realize the time was right to
activate his rooks and break down
White's Center but instead he played a
Knight to g5 attacking White's f3 pawn
and after King to g2 now I believe this
d5 break isn't quite as good because of
maybe just the same threats oh and
bishops do one as well sorry if Bishop
c1 would be winning I think unless
there's some some other tactics going on
but yeah just Bishop c1 would win the
knight so black has to solve this
problem so he actually just brings the
knight back and now we kind of see that
black is just lost lost time for no
apparent reason and now maybe he was
hoping for d5 and getting the rook into
D to check but he actually does not have
time for this so what do you think white
played here to try to take advantage o
Bishop f6 I don't think so I think he
answered a different move first but yeah
you've got the right idea
so what white wants to do is play Queen
to h4 and Bishop take that six and again
really hammered down White's or blacks
King on these dark squares so first
actually sorry white played rook to d1
trying to control this pawn break black
played Knight to d7 and h4 so White's
getting some space on the Kings side
maybe h5 h6 will be played to further
breakdown blacks remaining pawns um and
yeah the Queen will come in behind to
support or maybe the Queen will come to
c3 but obviously there are quite a few
threats and there
so black played f6 trying to stunt this
bishop because this diagonal he decided
really had too much pressure and black
was going to crack at some point
so after f6 King to h1 simply stepping
off this second rank where the King
might fall into some checks after this
pawn break d5 gets played and also
stepping off since any checks that might
come from a knight being placed on to f4
dr. King to h1 g6 kicking the knights
and bishops t1 was inserted and after
Queen to e5 where do you think the
knight one age six you have a civilian
chick
rook d5 uh right all right
um maybe we should add stockfish it
would know more than me but yeah looking
at it here I don't really see how blood
would be escaping from this
okay so night to be six oh and then
fritz actually wants to sack the Queen
at this point which I mean take that how
you will but yeah this is what the
engine recommends which I mean white
should be winning but maybe white
thought he had more here for some reason
well fair enough rook rook d5 is a very
good move but after your king - h1 g6
white went ahead and played Bishop to c1
now like we said and now Knight to h6
like you suggested out there so the King
comes to g7 and now how does white
continue the attack
35 now maybe
any other suggestion
H five so yeah these are the type of
ideas that I look good I think in the
game actually white opted for g5s so
again blacks whites usually attacking
along the dark squares and not the light
squares so h5 doesn't really make as
much sense because black can maybe
defend these dark squares now with
something like Knight to f4 and even g5
eventually once this Knight gets kicked
out but a first I think just nice f4 and
now you have some problems keeping this
Knight around right I'm not even sure
what white would play here
ah right so you would have to that's the
other thing is going to dimension if you
just play rook to d5 here which was the
other move that was suggested maybe
black can run away Knight f5 Misha page
six right right
so rook d5 what would suggested is
Knight f5 and then of course if if takes
Bishop h6 would win the Queen but yeah
of course maybe black can just sidestep
the threat and blacks King might might
be escape black queen excuse me might be
escaping
so in the game Jehovah opted for pawn to
g5 further attacking these dark squares
well so after b4 trying to get black
screen a square now how do you think why
continued Knight g4 is them suggested
any other mousse
rook g1 in the game actually I think 94
was either played this mover at some
point ahe for so we're rerouting the
knight to attack all of the key squares
as well as odd doing it with tempo by
outputting pressure and black screen so
black screen went to the square it made
for itself and now you want to take on
f6
um maybe blacks could just recapture
here Bishop h6 I think King h8 or will
not King h8 but a king f7 is safe enough
for the moment of course we need to
defend the night yeah we need to keep
the Knights offended but I think black
should be doing okay here
I mean maybe white is still winning
because his attack is really really
overpowering at this point but yeah blot
white instead opted for the simple Queen
to F to keep being the pawn defended
putting the Queen along this file and
obviously when I'm Queen trade and here
black played h5 trying to evict the
night once again so you what do you guys
want to play G takes h6 on passant I'm
not so sure that's been White's best
interest I'll look at it in a second
I will give you guys a chance to think
for a few seconds
yep Bishop d2 um you're on you've got
the the right idea but not not quite I
think so we want to move black screen to
a less a less optimal square so I think
in the game yet work to do is played and
now black Queen really has nowhere to go
I think probably the best Square for it
is just to come back to c6 but on c6 of
course it's giving up the defense of
this pawn so in the game black tried
Queen to a-1 and yet now of course she
takes f6 King h7 to avoid Bishop h6
check winning the Queen and now after
Queen to d2 it's really just over so the
game I think continue to feel more moves
nice f8 + f7 and here I believe is where
black chose resign but let's look at the
more interesting line which is Queen to
c6 how do you think white could have
continued here
and I click on f6 twice flipping your g5
Bishop g5 and then queen deep floor
without recapturing the night um that
could be interesting so I think we do
start with takes our quill will take
like this and then I you wanted to take
twice you but yeah I wanted to just play
we should be too but yet this also looks
we should be 595 Twinkie for what is
okay I'm wasn't it
okay we're struggling here let's back up
a bit what is my god can I can I make a
chess move
we might have to restart chat space ah
if I try to make a move I grab a pond
and it puts it somewhere this is very
interesting this just like two seconds
ago yeah yeah this is really this is
something can I draw an arrow no I can't
draw arrows
okay well let's really quick go over oh
wait I fixed it I knew I can do it all
right so yeah we're looking at of course
Bishop b2 here pinning the knight and
white will open up the King very shortly
after King f7g f6 Knight f4 rook to d1
and it's still a game I mean blacks not
getting checkmated immediately but this
pawn is quite strong and this bishop is
pretty much unstoppable on this diagonal
so black would have been hard-pressed to
a keep playing here but yeah like I said
in the game black instead just went to a
1 and then that falls into this tactic
with Queen to d2 and finally f7 with the
dual threat of checkmate and winning a
rope so here black resigned so the key
things to remember about this game are
that a
- six in the opening six
oh sorry instead of eight six yet um
yeah this could have been a another
option to help support d5 and give the
bishop a square but then the night is
the night is lacking in squares a bit
yeah and it's also blocking off this
diagonal from the bishop and this night
is really short on shoreland scores as
well so yeah I think the fly block opted
for a six but yet the key thing to
remember if black goes to a d6 maybe F 4
is the correct pawn break I mean it is
still quite good if you can get it in
but a d4 is the other pawn break to be
thinking about and maybe you can try to
take advantage of your opponent's
temporary temporary miss placement of
the bishop with moves like Knight a3
aiming for the c-4 square and after this
as well the second main point I wanted
to cover is that you really don't want
to be trading this Bishop off for your
opponent's Bishop if you can it all help
it
which is why white and certain 83 here
all right moving along now we're going
to look at a different first move from
blacks point of view so is this what I
want yeah I believe so
so today we're right now we're going to
be looking at B 3 and then d5 so in this
line blacks not really trying so much to
stop the bishop by placing upon here but
he's instead just going for a classical
center with d5 and something like Knight
f6 so we'll see how this develops after
Bishop to b2 Knight to f6 III again
preparing moves like s4 to keep this
diagonal open G 6s for like I said and
Bishop g7 Knight to f3 so again we're
really trying to control these dark
squares here and then this line black is
trying to oppose our Bishop directly
which if you noticed in the other ones
black ended up trying to play this
Bishop out to e7 to f6 or to d6 to e5 to
try to contest this Bishop and so in
this line blacks actually just doing it
straight away with the C and Quetta yep
Bishop f6 I believe is an option here
but in the game which is opted for f4
you'll most often see this if which I
have one more game which I don't think
we have time to get to today but the if
black works to play
f6 Knight of 6 right away Bishop b2 g6
here very often white will take on f6 to
a week in black's pawn structure and
then you get a very different type of
game where White's playing against these
pawns and obviously not trying to
improve this Bishop as he shared it off
but yeah I believe actually in this game
it also would have been an option for
white to take on f6 but white simply
chose a different route with f4 so nice
f3 and all of the arrows okay castles
and white continued development black
throws in this sort of strange move to
try to open instruct so we saw this idea
in the other game but here blacks
playing it much earlier with a much
different pawn structure as the pawns on
C 2 B 3 and a 2 are still working
together with the C to pawn also
defending b3 rather than being weakens
on c4 so should white respond to a5 with
the move like a 4 or do you think you
should just ignore it and continue
developing with castles or some other
moves
okay
you'd go away for yeah so yeah that's
what bent Larsen decided to do in this
game just stopping this pawn break now
that you haven't weakened your b3
squared with c4 yet and just stopping
the pawn break with a4 is quite
effective so that's what was played
Bishop to g4 and now we see black is
actually trying to put up a fight for
some of these dark squares by thinking
about turning off this Bishop for this
night which would we can be White's
control over these two squares and also
you'll see with this pawn on d5 this
Bishop really has no future anywhere the
most I can hope for is maybe coming to
a6 but that seems kind of difficult to
get in right now as b6 is kind of a
waste of time and yeah with this pawn on
d5 is not coming to 8e 6 and it's not
really doing a whole lot on f5 other
than becoming a target for whites Knight
later on with something like Knight to
d4 so Bishop c4 instead thinking about
trading off this Bishop for this knight
white castles black develops his Knights
and now white goes ahead to play Knight
to g5 so white actually wants to keep
this Knight and because obviously this
Bishop can never attack the dark squares
and this wisheth can never attack the
dark squares and this night might become
valuable for that purpose later on so
we'll see a trade on e2 and after Knight
to e8 black has succeeded in
neutralizing those bishops um there's
really no way for white to keep the
bishops on here
and so they get traded off as well so
this game actually went on for quite a
long time and now White's plans switch
from easing this bishop to his advantage
to just positioning this pieces and
their optimal squares so we'll see how
that went for him after next to c3 g6
defending the phone
Queen to g4
h6 kicking the night out and so now
White's thinking about trying to form
and attack somehow using this F pawn is
the lever but there's really not a great
hope of that in this position with this
Bishop traded off like if you can
imagine this night being off the board
and white having this Bishop instead
like this position would just be
fantastic for white so this is really
why you want to do everything in your
power to keep the bishop on the board
because you're attacking chances pretty
much go away once that Bishop is off the
Queen to d7 Queen to h4 avoiding the
trade Knight to f5 and the Queen comes
back to e1 so abandoning hope of
attacking on the on the Kings side maybe
you can argue he's created a couple
weaknesses but obviously the Queen's not
doing much anymore so he brings it back
to the center
Queen 67 here night to g3 was played
trying to trade off black spots piece e6
and now black gets kind of a fractured
bone structure but it really has no real
weaknesses and it controlled efore quite
nicely so not too bad at all for him
Queen back to h4 Queen to e7 and c4 so
this is how white opted to try to break
through on the Queen side with the C
pawn push so what do you think his idea
is with this obviously he he'd be quite
happy with this move when this B pawn is
a going to come under attack on the B
file and you can't ever really play b5
as we have that square guarded quite
well so what do you think his idea is if
after for example the move played in the
game for K to d8 yeah Julian yeah that's
right so he wants to actually play c5 so
the point of this move is it secures the
d4 square for the pieces as well as
eyeing the b6 and D 6 squares and so of
course black cannot take this pawn as it
would leave the night hanging
so instead the move rook to e8 was
played
so what continues was simply defending
the pawn black plays King to g7
improving its King defending the knight
once again and now the knight comes in
to d4 so we can really see how white is
still trying to maintain control of the
dark squares
even without the bishop so Knight to d7
was played in order to save this pawn we
have to trade Queens and now the move
rook to d1 come thinking about applying
pawn to b4 and attacking b7 rook to a8
trying to prevent it we go ahead and
play it anyways and now White's play is
really going to centralize around trying
to win this b7 pawn and using this a
pawn to win and sorry blacks play is
going to centralize around finding
activity first pieces I have it replying
some King side pawn breaks or just
piling up on this a pawn to prevent what
White's doing so we'll see how that one
works to a7 defending King to f2 Knight
to b8 looking at a 6 square as well as
bringing the rook in for defense Knight
to b3 rook to e4 and what do you think
white played here neat thing alright so
obviously this pawn is going to be under
attack if you come to b6 the night will
come to d7 do you think it's time on
giving up on the d4 square by playing
Knight back to d4 or give up on playing
xp3 with coming back to d4 or do you
think why it went ahead with d4 here
yeah that's right
so originally with c5 white was hoping
to have a nice night on the square but
it actually isn't accomplishing a great
deal here so after Knight to b3 he does
go ahead and just solidifies the spawn
structure with d4 even though it takes
away what might be an important square
from the night
so after d4 rook back to e7 we see king
after you get played 9 to 8 6 attacking
the rook so their work moves Knight back
to b8 so black is really just shuffling
around and claiming that white can never
really accomplish anything but we'll see
we'll see what white came up with soon
so Rick a1 Knight to d7 attacking the
rook so white kind of played an
interesting move here Julian yeah of
course
so rather than moving the rook white
simply played a 5 hoping for 90s b6
he takes b6 went after rook to e8 or
will sorry I think yeah we'll look at
Rick today white will play Knight to c5
and despite being an exchange down white
can't really be worse here it's tough to
claim that White's better or even like
winning but this would have been
slightly better for white probably most
likely it's just a draw but white would
have all of the winning chances with
this one game yeah you can you can try
for a bit so instead of like this I did
not to take the rook and simply played
Knight back to b8 again shuffling here
why it came to c1 just rerouting the
night
- eh - just just some endgame shuffling
and here black decided to come come in
with the h4 pawn to try to create some
counter play so if we were to ignore
this what do you think would happen what
would black play ed Julian yeah you
would try to come in through h8 into h3
or maybe h2 or h1 depending on what
happens in later positions so white
really needs to respond to this so how
do you think white can uh okay how do
you think white can respond to this this
idea g4 yeah so that's what was actually
played in the game so just g4 and after
takes takes f5 and back white succeeded
in keeping this h-file closed so now
that blacks a plaintiff up in the
opening the H while fails where do you
think he set his sights next yes so you
can't open the H file but you can in
fact open the G file
so after g5 takes takes king f2 knight
back kingi to avoiding a perpetual king
to h6 so blacks going to try to bring
his rook and or at least tie down a lot
of white and pieces to preventing the
Rick from coming in so why play Knight
to e2 check King get you King to f1
sorry after Knight to f6 Knight to f4 we
see white is slowly making his way
towards uh making a threat either with
putting this knight on e5 and thinking
about playing a six to a week in this
pawn well yeah that's that's the main
idea or there might be some Forex
threatens with the knight coming into e6
somehow
so we'll see what actually happened in
the game with Knight to g4 and here
white player 2 G 2 and here black played
what might be not the losing move but
where he started to go arrived so we
needed to keep pressure on White's pawns
with something like Rick te 8 or Rick to
a followed by rook to e8 and white
really has no chance in a playing on
here as like he will he will be forced
to a stay tied down to this pawn for
rest of the game and I mean black won't
be doing anything either but this is
what black should have gone for just
shut down all play instead after work to
aid
Rick a to a 8 we see King II to get
played so this pawn is well defended now
and after Knight to f6 we can trade off
a pair of rooks and rook to a One Nights
f6 and after Knight to d3 we see this
plan start to come to fruition so after
Knight g4 h3 kicking the knight from
defending the square knight to f6 95
here Knight to e4 was played again black
maybe could have tried to get the rook
in but instead went with Knight to e4
and after a six takes black actually
resigned here rather than play on the
resulting endgame which might have been
a bit early but white really should be
winning after takes d6 because the C
pawn is quite strong so really quickly
any questions I went through this game
pretty quickly because we were running
out of time but do you guys think you
see some of the seams in the opening now
with one b3 yes thank you guys for
watching I hope you guys enjoyed the
lecture I'll see you guys next week
maybe
[Music]